[Music]
[Music]
in early 2021 ubisoft announced a large
continuation and expansion of the
division universe
this included a number of multimedia
additions such as a mobile game a novel
new content for the division two and a
spin-off called the division heartland a
new free-to-play title being developed
by redstorm entertainment
since this announcement there has been
radio silence
but over the last few days we've
received an update from the community
claiming an exclusive reveal on
heartland including map details game
modes and classes
as the name heartland implies it will
take place in a small town setting
rather than the big cities of past games
in the series
silver creek is a small town on the
western side of the state of new york
southwest of buffalo
the town has a population of less than 3
000 people and is situated on the
outside of lake erie that separates the
canada u.s border
through the center of town runs two
creeks silver creek and walnut creek
that split off from lake erie
silver creek is also the new york to
chicago main line of csx transportation
and the new york buffalo chicago main
line of norfolk southern railway
which means that a lot of freight passes
through the region
heartland has two game modes storm and
excursion
excursion is a pve mode pitting players
against the ai
it has been described as a way to
prepare agents for the storm mode
the description itself says
explore alongside other friendly agents
to prepare the world for the coming
storm
storm is essentially the same thing but
as pve vp
division players should recognize us
from the dark zone that is present in
both the division and its sequel
teams are composed of three players
where they can explore loot and scavenge
the large open world map
the gameplay could be compared to escape
from tarkov or hunt showdown
where the goal is to survive
loot and extract from silver creek to
your base of operations
the aim is to earn more powerful gear to
take on greater challenges
as there are other players about these
upgrades will help you be better
prepared for these encounters
the map is a large open world
where players can explore and find loot
dotted throughout
like the division you'll find loot in
five different rarities
grey green blue purple and gold
there are also shd beacons that are
spread around the map
players can interact with these and
spend resources to unlock upgrades like
virus protection
virus clearance power ups and supply
drops
another feature of the map that is
relatively common in these br style
games
is the release of deadly gas around the
map
this could be the virus similar to the
contaminated areas we find in the base
game or perhaps it could be something
like dc 62 which was released in
washington dc
however rather than spreading from the
outside slowly creeping in these
contaminated areas can pop up from
anywhere
in order to avoid being downed by this
players can craft gas mask filters in
order to survive gas ridden areas
much like the division one and two there
is a base of operations in heartland the
base of operations is set up inside an
abandoned skating rink
this is the area where you can customize
your loadout matchmake for lobbies sell
previously extracted loot buy upgrades
and new weapons
this is also the place where you can
choose and enable projects and
assignments which will grant players
extra experience points per round if
successful
summing up the boo is your central hub
it is the area where players will
prepare their loadouts and craft
upgrades to prepare for the next round
of deployment
some of the options will have a direct
effect on the upcoming operation
such as the insertion point the stash
box buff tower
and extractor pod
at this stage there are six characters
you can choose from but other than
appearance there is nothing else that
really distinguishes their play style
however you will have the option of
playing from three different classes
weapon expert
the talents include tracking shot where
enemies are marked for five seconds
after damaging them with a firearm
and shared arma kit where arma kits
repair your armor as well as nearby
teammates
medic the talents are health recovery
where the health is restored after being
in cover for a short time and shared
health kit that will not only restore
your own health but teammates that are
close by
and survivalist whose talents include
loot detection which will highlight
nearby unopened crates and shared filter
of which i can only assume has something
to do with the gas filter you're wearing
and sharing the level of protection you
have with the rest of the team depending
on how close they are
i'm pretty late to the party with this
video but i had a few people asking for
my thoughts on it
although i haven't tried my hand and
escaped from tarkov i'm a big fan of
hunt showdown so i'm actually pretty
keen to see what this game has in store
for us
in all honesty i don't see this as being
something that would interest the
majority of the division players
i've never really thought of the
division as being a game that catered
for pvp
and while i can hear the division pvp
creators screaming at me already even in
the best state of pvp in the division
one it still felt super awkward
don't get me wrong i loved last stand
and i spent the majority of my time in
the dark zone in earlier updates
this was more of a side activity for me
or a way to get gear faster before they
remove the benefits of the high risk
high reward area from the game
the division heartland looks to be
shaping up as more of a pvp focused game
and in order to help them along with
this and remove some of the balancing
issues a lot of what makes the division
the division is being removed from the
game
i'm a pvp player just not a division pvp
player so i'm actually looking forward
to this
it is a franchise i love and hopefully a
story i can get behind regardless of how
little it may add
maybe this will be the first pvp
introduction that will help land the
division on the map
for those of you not interested in a
pvp-based division game i completely
understand but you need to remember
anything that helps the name grow will
be beneficial to the base game in the
long run which will in turn lead to
increased support and future updates
we need to remember that the division 2
was essentially written off a couple of
years ago as being a game that would no
longer be updated and supported by the
studio
but depending on how these other
additions to the franchise go we could
be seeing far more than just the seasons
on repeat and the next potentially last
update to the base division game
however i won't lie this is a free to
play game i'm reasonably concerned as to
how the marketplace will work
they've done it properly before but
based on recent calls from the higher up
ubisoft executives i have my doubts
if this becomes a pay-to-win title it's
dead in the water
or maybe they'll just add nfts
imagine it you could earn feylow's
missing eye
or the toys manny is always complaining
about
organic sweet sweet beard
okay i should probably stop talking
about this ubisoft might see it and get
some ideas
i obviously don't want this to happen
well maybe apart from unix beard this
from what i'm reading has a lot of
potential as a pvp game for the division
universe
other than the obvious teething issues
my main concern is the free to play
model
so i'll be keeping a close eye on this
yubi hasn't had the best of track
records recently with these models
so i hope we don't just see this burn
out and die within 12 months
we haven't actually had any official
news come from the studio yet so perhaps
some of these concerns will be addressed
all we know at this point is that we
should be seeing heartland release
sometime before march 2023
but if i had to put my money on it i
would say mid-2022
anyway i hope you found this informative
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]